so steve schmidt who is of course a a
former republican now he is a like
complete never trump
crazy person he said on msnbc
that the fly landing on mike pence was a
sign that he was satan
here was steve schmidt last night i mean
i don't think it's ever a good sign when
a fly lands on your
head for two minutes you know that's a
that's a sign all through history of sin
and historically biblically uh maybe
you wouldn't normally say this after uh
you wouldn't it's only safe to say this
sorry after midnight but
you know the a fly he who commands the
fly has always been seen historically
the mark of the devil
okay it didn't stop there obviously you
got andrea
mitchell andrea mitchell then went to
the mansplaining mansplaining
routine she says i asked a man i know
what he thought of the debate he said
the debate was over when she said mr
vice president you are interrupting me
then she needs to hang out with like men
who exist not ones that exist in her
imagination
you know like men who are biologically
men because that's crazy
okay the minute she said you're
interrupting me susan page interrupted
her we showed you the clip
susan page interrupted her and then
trump and then pence jumped in
and then she's like well she said stop
interrupting me to a man that was
standing up for women everywhere
women power this was the talking point
in the media as soon as you are
relegated
to saying that she was the victim of
pence's wild
sexism yeah good luck with that van
jones on cnn
did the did the same thing he suggested
that pence was the quote unquote
mansplainer in chief just because he is
a man and he is explaining things does
not mean he is mansplaining things he
was not talking down to kamal harris
it's a political debate yeah idiots it's
a political debate here is van jones
trying to try out this
tired talking point she was not overly
assertive throughout this entire debate
was a man
i understand that but okay and and then
you get george stephanopoulos the
keebler elf
suggesting there was tons of
mansplaining last night just endless
endless mansplaining
last night from george stephanopoulos
stephanopoulos objective news anchor
because obviously mike pence uh his
former television commentator does have
a very calm demeanor
but i think a lot of people were
noticing some mansplaining going on
tonight
okay then stop there nicole wallace on
msnbc she did the same thing but
she didn't just go there she got full-on
sexist against mike pence
okay so you're you're allowed to you're
not allowed to interrupt camel harris
under any circumstances
ever ever ever if you do you're sexist
stop it you're a bad person cut it out
okay but
but nicole wallace literally called
mike pence flaccid and limp in the
debate
oh is she making a a pun about his penis
yes of course she is because you're
allowed to say whatever you want about
men in our society
but if you interrupt a woman if you so
much as interrupted a woman during a
debate
it's because you hate women you see you
hate them
hate them she said the only people they
have in their coalition
after last week's barn burner from trump
were the grievance voters this will not
land well
with them and then she suggested that
perhaps
she actually went on to suggest nicole
wallace that perhaps
mike pence was feeling under the weather
right she started talking about the fact
that his eyes looked a little pink so
maybe he has covered
so that's her narrative now we're going
to speculate about mike pence's health
maybe he has covered who the hell knows
maybe he does mark ruffalo
signed in as well to uh to join in the
fun
the idiot actor a man with uh fewer than
ten brainteals rubbed together
he tweeted out just going over it all in
my head the way mike pence constantly
interrupted and spoke over kamal harris
was the prime example of white
male supremacy and it's common dismissal
and disrespect for black women
i i have a question let's say that the
sexes
had been reversed and let's say that
kamala harris had been the one who
mildly interrupted mike pence and pence
had said you're interrupting me you're
interrupting me stop interrupting me
then they would claim that he was being
defensive and aggressive with kamala
harris
there is in fact a double standard but
the double standard is applied against
men and not against women in these
circumstances that is perfectly obvious
it's been obvious from the media
coverage
since before the debate this is
ridiculous
essie cup on cnn she did the same thing
she said that uh she blasted
mike pence she said his debate was
infuriating he made her skin crawl skin
crawl you see i know mike pence i've met
mike pence i've interviewed mike pence
and at one time i found him very
impressive
tonight he made my skin crawl
uh and i think showed that you can uh
be insulting without using insults um
you know the constant interruptions the
mansplaining
the condescending to both of the women
on that stage tonight and and and the
not answering questions the gaslighting
i found infuriating okay the the this is
just
i'm sorry it's very silly it is very
obvious pence one the media's coverage
proves that pence won okay so now here's
the question can this turn into momentum
can this turn into momentum and the
answer is maybe
but trump has to get out of his own way
once again this campaign is not about
mike pence if pence were the
presidential candidate i think
the republican ticket would now be ahead
in the polls donald trump needs to get
out of his own way
he needs to do the same defense of his
policies that pence did
he can do it in trumpian fashion he can
but he needs to actively defend his own
policies
rather than fulminating over whatever he
saw on the tvs today
and if that happens maybe this thing
turns around if it doesn't then the
problems will continue for the trump
campaign but
again well i think the takeaway last
night is that trump's policies are
excellent how do you know
because mike pence was able to win going
away winning a walk
against kamala harris simply by saying
the policies out loud and pointing out
that democrats have never had to answer
a single difficult question
about their own policies and in fact
refuse to answer their own policies
right now if you listen to kamala harris
last night democrats are the parties of
anti-green new deal
low taxes and pro fracking as as uh
elizabeth brooding an actual socialist
writing for the washington post said
it seems like if this is the new
democratic party they've left the left
completely behind of course it isn't
they're lying
but just demonstrates how much they have
to lie in order to convince the american
people they are not who they actually
are
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button